okay today I'm going to talk to you
about power in circuits so to help
illustrate what I'm talking about today
I'm just gonna have a real real simple
simple circuit here all it has is a cell
and a filament lamp so let's say this
filament lamp has a power of 80 watts
now what power actually means is the
energy transferred or the energy
transferred per second so it means every
single second how much energy is being
transferred for example by this
component so for this component here
this filament lamp every single second
it's transferring 80 joules of energy so
that means if we just have a quick think
after 1 second 2 seconds 3 seconds 4
second or 5 seconds every single second
80 joules of energy is being transferred
here being released as light and this to
the thermistor so after 1 second it
releases a teachers after the second
second it would have released 160 jaw's
then 240 tools after 4 seconds 320 and
after 5 seconds 400 joules because every
single second that's how much energy is
transferring 80 joules
every single second now the equation
triangle that we need to know for this
one for power is this right here there's
actually a few different equations but
we'll look at this one first so E is
energy transferred which is indoors
P is power which is measured in watts
and finally T is time and that's
measured in seconds so what we can see
is we can actually double-check this
kind of common-sense idea here using our
equation triangle so said if every
second with its it's transferring 80
joules of energy then let's use this
right here energy is power times time so
after one second our power of this is 80
times 1 we were transferred 82
in two seconds power times time we would
have done eighty times two which is a
hundred and sixty and so on so to find
out the amount of energy produced or
energy transferred by a component we
just need to do the power multiplied by
the time so an interesting point to know
as well is the unit watts is exactly the
same as joules per second that's all
that what's means how many joules are we
transferring per second now the other
equation triangle we need to know for
this one is P over I times V and what
that is showing is our power equals our
current times our voltage now let's have
a think what that means let's just
quickly have a think about this circuit
here let's imagine if I've got an
ammeter right here and I've got a
voltmeter here to measure the potential
difference so our power so P equals
power which is measured in what's our
power remember that's how much energy is
transferred every second now my my
potential difference my potential
difference is how much energy is being
transferred between two different points
is the difference in energy between two
different points so if I've got more
energy being transferred across a
component I'm going to have more energy
transferred per second also what my R
meter measures is the flow of charge
around the circuit so if I have more
charge flowing round or of charge
flowing around at a faster rate I'm also
gonna have a higher power so let's have
a quick think about that so let's
imagine to begin with let's imagine we
begin with I had 10 amps and eight volts
so I could see at the moment to find my
power I do current times voltage so my
power would be 10 times 8 so my power
would be 80 watts
I'd be transferring 80 jewels every
single second now let's imagine if I
increased my current and kept everything
else the same so if I increase my
current that just means that I'm the
same amount of energy is being
transferred by this component but it's
going to be transferring at a much
faster rate because my current has gone
up so let's say I've now got a hundred
amps instead that's going to result in
my power going up because now I've got
100 times eight so my power would now be
800 watts similarly if I increase my
potential difference so let's say now
I've got 10 volts instead because more
energy is being transferred across this
component I'm also going to have a
bigger power so this time for this
example here I have 10 times 100 which
equals a thousand watts so by either
increasing my current or increasing my
potential difference I'm also increasing
the power now the final equation we need
to know is P equals I squared times R
which simply means power equals your
current squared times your resistance so
in order to do this all you need to do
is find the current in your circuit
figure out the resistance so for example
if there's a resistor in there that is
10 ohms then all you need to do is do
your current squared multiplied by your
resistance thank you so just to
summarize power is the energy
transferred per second by a component
thank you